we now come to our last major class of
counting problems we will count the
number of ways that a given set can be
partitioned into pieces of given sizes
we start with a set that consists of n
different elements and we have our
persons we want to give n1 items to the
first person give and two items to the
second person and so on and finally we
want to give n sub R items to the Arth
person these numbers and 1 & 2 up to n R
are given to us how many items each
person should get and these numbers must
add to n so that every item in the
original set is given to some person we
want to count the number of ways that
this can be done this is the number of
ways that we can partition a given set
into subsets of prescribed sizes let's
use C to denote the number of ways that
this can be done we want to calculate
this number C instead of calculating it
directly we're going to use the same
trick that we employed when we counted
combinations and derived the binomial
coefficient that is we're going to
consider a much simpler counting problem
the problem of ordering and items taking
the n items in our original set and
putting them in an ordered list of
course we know in how many ways this can
be done ordering n time and items can be
done in n factorial ways this is the
count of the number of permutations of n
items but now let us think of a
different way of ordering the n items an
indirect way it proceeds according to
the following stages we start with the n
items and we first distribute them to
the different person
having done that then we asked person
one to take their items order them and
put them in the first n1 slots of our
list then person two takes their items
and puts them in the next and two slots
in our list we continue this way and
finally the last person takes the items
that they possess and put them in the
last n sub R slots in this list in how
many ways can this process be carried
out we have C choices on how to
partition the given set into subsets
then person one has n 1 factorial
choices on how to order the N 1 items
that that person possesses person 2 has
n 2 factorial choices for how to order
the end two items that it possesses and
so on until the last person who has n R
factorial choices for ordering their
elements this multistage process results
in an ordered list of the n items this
is the number of ways this multistage
process can be carried out on the other
hand we know that the number of possible
orderings of the items is n factorial so
we have this equality we can solve this
for C and we find the answer that the
number of ways that the n items can be
partitioned into subsets of the given
sizes is n factorial divided by the
product of the factorials of the
different and eyes this particular
expression is called the multinomial
coefficient and it generalizes the
binomial coefficient the binomial
coefficient was referring to the K
where we essentially split assets into
one subset with K elements and then the
second subset gets the remaining
elements so the special case where R is
equal to 2 and N 1 is equal to K n 2
equals to n minus K this corresponds to
a partition of a set into two subsets or
what is the same just selecting the
first subset and putting everything else
in the second subset and you can check
that in this particular case the
expression for the multinomial
coefficient agrees with the expression
that we had derived for the binomial
coefficient